Speaker 1: Well, the National Rifle Association
has put out a statement responding to the shooting
in Uvalde, Texas. You may also recall that
the National Rifle Association is having
its annual convention in Texas starting tomorrow,
Friday. Donald Trump is scheduled to speak there.
Republican Texas Governor Greg Abbott is scheduled
to speak there. Ted Cruz is scheduled to speak
there. So the NRA puts out this response and I
don't know whether to call it disgusting. I don't
know whether to call it depraved or dystopian, but
it's definitely really bad. Take a look at this.
The NRA's statement on the shooting is, quote,
Our deepest sympathies are with the families and
victims involved in this horrific and evil crime.
On behalf of our members, we salute the courage
of school officials, first responders and others
who offered their support and services. Okay.
Although there's increased questions as to whether
how and why the police confronted the shooter
outside the school, and then the shooter went in
and spent 40 to 60 minutes shooting up a classroom
until police ultimately went in and stopped him.
Kind of a weird thing. The NRA continues to say,
although an investigation is underway and
facts are still emerging. We recognize this
was the act of a lone, deranged criminal. A lone,
deranged criminal with really easy access to guns.
With no requirement for gun insurance. With no
limitations on high capacity firearms despite
being only 18 years old. Thanks to, in part,
the lobbying actions of the NRA. And by the way,
the whole you know, as they say here, a lone,
deranged criminal gets to the mental illness
component. Also in a country that says half of
the country says mental illness is the problem,
but they won't fund mental health treatment. As we
gather in Houston, the statement goes on to say.
We will reflect on these events, pray for the
victims, recognize our patriotic members in
the midst of this. Your members are the
patriots. What? And pledged to redouble
our commitment to making our schools secure. So on
the prayer I'm a little sick of the after the fact
prayer once people are dead. If the prayer
worked, why wouldn't it prevent the shootings?
If you pray the right way, pray to prevent
the shootings, and yet they keep happening.
And the most insidious thing is we're going to
redouble our efforts to make schools secure.
The NRA exists to sell guns. Okay. When they
say redouble our efforts to make schools secure.
They're talking about arming teachers
and arming everyone to sell more guns
for their clients. Their clients are the
gun manufacturers. At the end of the day,
a disgusting statement from the NRA. Obviously,
the convention should be canceled, but in fact,
Donald Trump is doubling down on speaking
there. And we'll get to that a little bit later.